le conseil de sécurité je vous le disais
sur le point de se réunir à new york on
va prendre tout de suite sur ce thème
donc de cet incident nucléaire en
ukraine on va tout de suite prendre la
direction de new york justement nous
attend notre correspondant emmanuel ça
martin bonjour
emmanuel concrètement qu'est ce qu'on
peut attendre de cette réunion en
urgence du conseil de sécurité
écoutez comme d'habitude des
condamnations d'un côté de la plupart
des pays qui feront qui seront là et
puis autour de la table du conseil de
sécurité et puis de l'autre côté une
défense de la russie on sait déjà que la
russie affirme que ce sont des tirs
ukrainienne ukrainien en réalité qui ont
été faits contre contre sept centrales
nucléaires contre toute évidence
d'ailleurs et puis de l'autre côté bien
on va entendre d'abord un rapport de
l'énergie de l'agent de l'énergie
atomique qui va venir faire le point de
la situation d'hier ces inquiétudes ou
pas il semble que ce soient rassurés
depuis le fait que cet incendie était
éteint qu'il n'y ait pas eu d'atteinte
direct aux réacteurs on va l'entendre
tout de suite de la part de la bouche de
leur presse du représentant de l'agencé
et puis les occidentaux vont venir à
nouveau condamné cette action russe
cette violence russe et puis appelé
aussi encore une fois au cessez le feu
on a entendu aussi tout de suite juste
avant son entrée dans le conseil de
sécurité l'ambassadeur français rappelé
que la france présenté essayer de
travailler sur une résolution pour
appeler à
la d'humanitaire l'axé universal à
l'aide humanitaire partout en ukraine et
des sans doute des couloirs humanitaires
et puis aussi un cessez le feu c'est une
un texte de résolution sur lesquels les
français travaillent depuis plusieurs
jours en coordination notamment avec le
mexique emmanuel l'ukraine a accusé
aujourd'hui la russie de terreur
nucléaire clairement cet incident a
marqué les esprits ce que ça paierait
est ce que ça peut faire évoluer
certaines positions est ce que ça peut
amener concrètement certains à revoir le
soutien ou le soutien tacite accordée à
la russie
écoutez or on le verra pour l'instant le
le le la plupart des diplomates auxquels
on a pu parler pense que non ça ne
changera pas parce que d'abord il ya
très peu de soutien ouverts à la russie
on l'a vu avec la résolution de voir
l'assemblée générale et il y a deux
jours finalement seulement quatre pays
se sont portés au côté ont voté contre
cette résolution aux côtés de la russie
les autres se sont abstenus et ils
s'abstiennent ils vont sans doute
continuer de le faire évidemment on va
continuer de regarder avec beaucoup
d'intérêt ce que va dire la chine
pendant sept pendant cette réunion du
conseil de sécurité la chine qui va sans
doute manifesté ses inquiétudes mais qui
pour l'instant a toujours accepté les
explications russe et mis un peu dos à
dos les deux parties a essayé d'avoir
une espèce de position de neutralité
tout le temps condamnant leur tour le
recours à la force donc on va voir si le
discours chinois évolué mais peu de gens
s'attendent à le voir plus
d'observateurs s'attendent à le voir
évoluer en tout cas à court terme ici à
new york aux nations unies et on va
suivre avec vous cette dans les heures
qui viennent cette réunion d'urgence du
conseil de sécurité merci emmanuel
saint-martin correspondant à new york
merci d'avoir été en direct avec nous